we you have to remember when you watch
something like this movie not a single
bit of it is random or accidental
none of it because you know they had to
draw I don't remember how many frames
per second these things are 30 maybe
maybe it's a little less than that but
it's high-quality animation and so
someone had to paint 30 pictures to get
a second of this you're not doing that
accidentally it's really expensive and
everyone has to agree on exactly what's
going to happen and you might say well
do the people who are doing this
consciously know what they're doing and
answer that is well sort of just like
you do you know it's yes they know and
no they don't and they know because
they're really smart and gifted and all
that but they don't know because it's
not all articulated plus they're working
in a group so they know and don't know
just like you do when you're watching it
and so and and when you do anything else
so now they're also guided by what you
might call they're guided by their
unconscious in the in the Freudian and
in the cognitive way partly because
you're unconscious value structures
determine the direction and content of
your perceptions so it's built right
into the way you move your eyes because
you tend to look at things you value
right or are things you're afraid of
like you look at things with valence and
part of the decision about what has
value is dependent on the implicit
structure of your moral system your
purse because morality is about what's
good and what isn't and that's been
partly a conscious construction of you
but it's partly something you've been
you picked up by interacting with people
like mad ever since you were born
you don't know all the rules anymore
than the damn cricket did you just don't
and you can't because you're too
complicated but you act them out and
then you also have representations of
how people act in your imagination
dreams are that's what it's dream is
that's what a fantasy is that's what
that little movie that plays inside your
head would you remember what you did is
and you only remember the gist you know
so even the the imagistic representation
of your behavior in your past which is
basically your episodic memory it's
already selecting and molding and
turning it into a relatable story it
can't help but do that it's the only way
you can represent it and so you don't
know how you do that or why you do that
but part
it's governed by this implicit morality
that's part of your procedural memory
system part of the way you act and part
of the way you move your eyes and listen
to things and focus on them that's all
being instantiated inside of you because
of this immense social your biology but
also this immense social project that
you're continually engaged in and so
that informs what you remember it
informs what you imagine it informs what
we collectively imagine it informs what
we can collectively understand and
partly what you're doing well you become
conscious of yourself is to map the
implicit structures that already
constitute you from society into
explicit representation that's what self
understanding means and you know when
you have that moment of insight about
something you've done it's like you're
watching your this repetitive behavior
that you've manifested probably that got
you in trouble
you know it's your characteristic way of
falling accidentally into chaos and you
talked about it your problems you talked
about them with your friends you talked
about them and maybe you have dreams
about them and you're you're trying to
relate them and you have memories about
them that you can't get rid of because
they're negatively toned so you talk
about them and then someone comes up
with a little statement that links them
together causally do you think aha
that's what I'm doing and then maybe you
can stop doing it or at least you or at
least maybe then you can think up some
strategies for not doing it anymore but
it's not like you know it's like you're
acting it out you know it that way but
until that's all until the
representation matches that pattern that
clique of insight doesn't occur and
that's like a revelation it's a really
good way of thinking about it because
the knowledge is there in its implicit
form and all of a sudden bang it's being
made explicit as a fantasy maybe or else
also as a as a set of semantic
statements you know maybe you're you
have a crush on someone and you don't
notice it and maybe you find yourself
having a fantasy about them you think oh
that means something that indicates
something maybe you don't want to know
that that's what you want but the
fantasy will tell you and one of the
things you suggested and this is sort of
out of the Freudian tradition of free
associations is
watch yourself watch your fantasies
because they're always happening and so
and they'll tell you something and so
one of the things I do when when I'm
interacting with my clients is we'll
have a discussion and then they'll their
eyes will drift a little bit and I'll
know that they're that something's
flitted through their mind you know and
that means we've touched on something
that has multiple multiplicity of
elements and so I'll stop and say look I
noticed that you maybe you tear it up
that's another thing to really watch or
maybe you like or you drifted at least
it's like it's because some other
thought has entered your field of
consciousness and then if you can get
the person to grab those thoughts to
notice them then you can often figure
out the avenues along which that
particular conversation might unfold
that's a complex that's a union complex
or a psychoanalytic complex it's like
there's an emotional core that produces
a whole range of associated ideas and
that thing's got a life it's like a
micro personality and it might have
resentment in it might have anger it's
often negative emotion tinge because the
negative emotion tinged episodes are
still problems and they will emerge
automatically because your threat
detection systems force them onto your
consciousness essentially so you watch
and when you drift you'll drift and the
fantasy is partly a representation of
the problem space you know what that
happens when you wake up at 3 in the
morning and you're worried about things
right because actually what happens is
you wake up during threat processing and
if you're depressed actually that gets
so intense you can't sleep so then you
just lay there all night worrying not
fun and those are fantasies about the
negative elements of your past present
and future
then the fantasies can also breed
solutions and that's partly why Freud
regarded dreams as wish fulfillment it's
partly and he wasn't that was where he
stopped it's not correct it's partially
correct it's like the fantasy will
provide you with a problem and a
potential solution but they're more like
problem identification mechanisms the
fantasies with the possibility of a
solution built in and so a way of
thinking about that is that you
can generate potential futures so
they're like each segregate able
environments according to the rules of
your fantasy then you can generate
little avatars of yourself that inhabit
each of those little universes and you
can run them as simulations and then you
can watch what happens in the simulation
and if it's a catastrophe then you don't
have to act it out and that's exactly
not exactly that's akin to what you're
doing when you go watch a movie
except that is much more coherent and
well thought through you know and then
it than just a dream which is often
quite fragmentary and that's part
because the dream is willing to
sacrifice coherence to play with
category structures you know and that's
why in dreams things can change from one
thing into another really weirdly or
scenes can change from one scene into
another without a logic the logic gets
loosened so that the expanse of your
thinking can widen and it's it's not
it's dangerous to do that and that's
partly why you do it when you're asleep
and paralysed you know you don't run
around and backed out your your suit of
Pottle fantasies you know where you're
stretching yourself out into the world
there's no risk exactly and so although
it can be bad enough so you wake up in
terror you know but that's better than
being in a crocodile's mouth by a large
margin